habituellement fermés au public le
centre d'entraînement pour chevaux de
course de maisons laffitte ouvre samedi
matin ses portes
par petits groupes de 15 personnes vous
pourrez découvrir les 60 hectares et
plusieurs kilomètres de pistes propriété
de france galop le centre d'entraînement
n'est pas ouvert au public puisque comme
vous le voyez avec les chevaux qui
évolue autour de nous on peut pas se
permettre d'avoir des gens qui
déambulent comme ça sur le sur ces lieux
donc l'office du tourisme organise des
visites encadrées par des professionnels
du monde des courses ils peuvent voir le
travail des chevaux le matin et ensuite
ils ont une visite d'écurie pour pouvoir
discuter avec l'entraîneur et voir
comment s'organise le travail et comment
s'organise la vie de l'écurie près de
500 chevaux de course s'entraîner ici
tous les jours ils sont montés par ce
qu'on appelle des lads les cavaliers qui
s'occupe d'entraîner les chevaux pour
les jo qui en fait les chevaux sont des
athlètes comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
donc il ya un pro qui t'ont qui ont un
programme de courses et donc ils sortent
effectivement tous les jours samedi et
dimanche compris jour férié il n'y a pas
de repos pour les chevaux de course et
leurs entraîneurs et le personnel qui
gravitent autour
ce centre d'entraînement est le seul en
ile de france pour les chevaux de
courses de galop une opportunité unique
donc de découvrir cet environnement très
important à maisons laffitte
je pense que pour des gens qui habitent
à maisons-laffitte je pense qu'il ya des
gens qui habitent dans la partie ville
et non pas dans le parc qui se rendent
pas forcément compte de ce que
représente le cheval à maisons laffitte
et je pense que c'est une bonne
opportunité de découvrir notre centre
d'entraînement et même pour les communes
avoisinantes
une visite est organisée ce samedi 3
juillet à 9 heures une autre date est
aussi proposé le 31 juillet prochain